When you want to use a database
in your application,
first you need to create
the database and give it a name.
You'll use the create
database command for this.
The name you give it here is the same
name you'll use to connect to
the database from your code.
The opposite of create in SQL is drop.
I'm not sure why.
Maybe database programmers
used to be really clumsy.
Anyway, the way to remove
a database is drop database.
And the way to remove
a table is drop table.
All of these commands have options.
You can look up in the documentation
if you ever need them.
When you drop a database or
table, there's no confirmation.
No, did you really mean to do that,
warning.
So, don't do it if you
don't really mean it.